Oh
for the first time in the Elder Scrolls
series Elder Scrolls online Tamriel
unlimited allows players to travel to
all nine provinces of Tamriel from the
familiar volcanic land of morrowind
and the mountain peaks of Skyrim to the
vast deserts of Hammerfell and lush
canopies of Vallon wood
cities across Tamriel are home to
merchants guilds banks taverns and a
host of urban adventures but travel off
the beaten path into the world's
boundless beautiful landscapes and you
will find an expansive variety of life
hunt animals and fish bountiful streams
to create beneficial meals for you and
friends or scour the land for wood and
artifacts to create weapons and magical
enchantments but there are dangers in
the wild as well monsters roam the open
world and the darkest dungeons of
Tamriel and the remote corners of the
world are home to unimaginable powers
you needn't travel far to find adventure
as the Ruby throne in Serie Dell sits
empty and the world is in the midst of a
vicious conflict that divides Tamriel
into three warring factions each of the
armies in the three banners war is
commanded by a determined and
captivating leader king Emmerich of High
Rock commands the Daggerfall covenant
with the utmost political savvy
the regal Queen I renewed xan alliance
of elves and Khajiit at the helm of the
ebonheart pact stands your and thus
called King a powerful nord warrior with
the future of Tamriel at stake who you
choose to follow will shape your ongoing
gameplay experience while the war for
the Ruby throne rages in serie dill a
darker more sinister plot threatens the
very existence of Tamriel from beyond
death the Daedric
Molag Bal has launched an offensive to
merge Tamriel into the plane of
Coldharbour Molag Bal does not act alone
Lord mana Marco the legendary
necromancer sits at his right hand
devising schemes in the physical world
you will find allies along your journey
to aid you on your quest but it is
ultimately up to you to save all of
Tamriel the sheer scope and beauty of
Tamriel is brought to life in Elder
Scrolls online Tamriel unlimited it is a
world comprised of dynamic combat
compelling lore and social opportunities
that all come together to create an
amazing online role-playing experience
the living world of Tamriel beckons will
you answer